there's trouble in paradise over at the
european central bank what am i talking
about obviously we know that inflation
is raging around the world here in the
united states inflation is at 8.5
percent and over in europe it's at 7.5
recently the ecb staff they went ahead
and they asked their leadership we want
higher pay raises but that's not exactly
going to happen here's what you need to
know any time that inflation is raging
on and your pay raise isn't at least as
high as inflation if not more it means
you're actually getting a pay cut in
purchasing power terms and now as that
ecb staff is asking for a higher pay
raise their leadership saying no we've
got to hear brand new news that
christine lagarde has shot down the idea
of the ecb staff getting any sort of pay
raise actually linked to inflation if we
take a look at that inflation it's seven
and a half percent and it doesn't look
like it's going to be stopping anytime
soon
now if the inflation's at seven and a
half percent you got to ask yourself
what exactly is the pay raise for
employees this year well it's only about
1.5
that means that the ecb staff is
literally getting about a six percent
pay cut it's not exactly what you would
want if you work at a central bank now
of course the central bank employees
they're a little bit more intelligent a
little bit better well-versed in
economics and purchasing power than your
average employee they understand that
inflation's at 7.5
and our raise is only 1.5 we're actually
getting paid less for doing the same
work now naturally as they've made the
ask to link pay raises to inflation
christine lagarde and the rest of the
leadership team they said we don't want
to do that of course they don't
inflation's too high she wrote in an
email to the staff and she said that she
understands that the figure has
disappointed many of them because of
high inflation we understand why
inflation is a concern for many of you
as it is for many people outside the ecb
but of course thoughts and prayers and
understanding doesn't pay the bills and
so the ecb refusing to actually match
pay raises to inflation is a big problem
those people who are working actually
get the pay raise they've got a unique
point of view as well we've got a quote
here that states our real salary cut has
now widened to six percent and ecb's
management is asking us that all workers
in europe to take the hit for the sake
of maintaining price stability clearly
this line of reasoning is not something
that we and other european workers can
accept so naturally what's going to end
up happening here so continue to be a
debate i don't foresee the central bank
giving people seven and a half eight
percent pay raises but i also don't see
inflation going away anytime soon and so
naturally you've got ecb staff only
getting that 1.5 pay raise and they
realize they're getting paid six percent
less but it's not just central bank
staff around the world it's every single
worker if you work in an environment
where there's seven and a half eight and
a half percent inflation and you didn't
get a seven and a half or eight and a
half percent increase to your pay you're
also getting paid less for doing the
same amount of work this is the problem
with high inflation when pay doesn't
keep up there's a big big problem and
we're only starting to see the cracks in
the armor the ecb staff gets it and
they're on the forefront imagine when
everyone else starts to realize that
they're actually taking pay cuts for
doing the same work high inflation is a
nasty thing
and we want it to go away as soon as
possible
but ultimately employers they're gonna
have to also address this
because if you're paying people less
money in purchasing power terms
eventually they have enough